premier thème ben voilà c'est anne
hidalgo meilleure candidate pour 2022
parce qu'au lendemain des régionales on
constate une accélération de la maire de
paris elle était ce matin sur france 2
je vous propose de l'écouter
je pense que les propositions que je
peux porter à la fois en venant de cette
expérience qui est la mienne en ayant
l'écologie comme cap pour transformer
l'économie de notre pays mais aussi les
questions d'égalité de lutter contre les
inégalités dramatique qui sont en train
de miner notre pays
je pense qu'il y aura sans aucun doute
des propositions qui intéresseront les
français la zone est immense alors en
parallèle parce que les choses sont bien
faites deux sans éluder principalement
des maires de gauche ont lancé un appel
à sa candidature pour nous c'est anne
patrick peloux pour vous c'est anne
aussi pour moi pour l'instant c'est pour
l'instant si je cherche un programme
d'accord alors elle va prendre ce matin
on n'avait pas ce qu'elle a choisi parce
que je suis de gauche d'accord une
culture de gauche sans parti monsieur
culture de gauche pour la culture et
et je dirais pour la lutte contre la
pauvreté
c'est sûr que nous sommes vraiment par
rapport à ce que disait voltaire
en son temps nous sommes de plus en plus
avec un petit groupe d'individus qui
profite d'un grand groupe d'individus et
ce grand groupe d'individus passe son
temps en fait à nourrir le petit groupe
d'individus basse et des profits et
c'est tout ce qu'on voit et vous pouvez
décliner sa aussi bien dans les médias
quand on voit les rachats qui lie à par
tf1 qui rachète rtl m6 etc
donc il ya il ya il ya quelque chose qui
se passe dans la société d'inégalitaire
pour reprendre ce que vient de dire anne
hidalgo
bon maintenant il le profil d'anne
hidalgo le mot séduirait ou non mais ça
ça peut coller mouais mais ça ne collera
pas s'il n'y a pas de programme derrière
d'accord c'est à dire que les régionales
c'est bien là le crash-test la une de
marianne et juste c'est en fait ils ont
fait une liste d'union de la gauche aux
régionales en ile-de-france c'est c'est
très beau un second tour voilà
oui le programme et on s'aperçoit qu'en
creusant les programmes sont totalement
disparate etc
et si vous voulez c'est un peu court
aussi de dire on va mettre de l'écologie
à toutes les pages
qu'est ce que ça veut dire je vais y
aller enfin moi ce que j'ai vu notamment
avec la crise de lakovic 19
c'est con ça nous a explosé à la figure
de voir qu'on a perdu notre souveraineté
sur les médicaments a perdu notre
souveraineté sur le matériel médical
donc ça veut dire réindustrialiser la
france qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour
la gauche de réindustrialiser la france
c'est c'est c'est un enjeu absolument
majeur
on va y venir oh oh non mais on
reviendra sur le fond je vais dans la
marge de france oui bien sûr ça va être
le débat sur la retraite
bien sûr et sur la société qui est basée
sur l'âge qu'ils se trompent parce que
on n'est pas vieux passé 40 ans et on
n'est pas un enfant en dessous de 30 ans
qui fait qu'on a une société qui
construit en fait votre vie entre 30 et
c'est totalement débile c'est débile bon
ce qui veut dire que et ça c'est le
docteur qui vous parle vous avez des
gens qu'on 60 65 ans qui sont en pleine
forme
donc il faut revoir la conception de la
retraite par contre vous avez des gens
qui a 40-45 ans ont usé qu il faut
revoir totalement sa et c'est une idée
de gauche ou parce que si la gauche
reste avec des idées des années 60 est
elle ne gagnera pas bon alors je suis
pas sûr qu'un tous les candidats de
gauche vous séduiront du coup sur le
fond peut-être qu'on va s'arrêter sur la
surface parce que sinon ça vous fera pas
adrien maths ou alors il ya votre une on
va parler de votre article
on voit dans les sondages que anne
hidalgo ne décolle pas depuis quatre
cinq mois qu'elle est dans le paysage
politique national c'est quoi c'est
entre 5 et 9 c'est quoi le problème
alors le problème c'est d'abord la
faiblesse de la gauche en fait on parle
beaucoup de le meilleur candidat de la
gauche qui pour représenter la gauche et
c est à mon avis il ya deux problèmes
quand on parle de ça le premier problème
c'est la faiblesse de la gauche qui même
rassemblé et je viendrai sais pas si
simple doit aller marcher à 25% en gros
de la population dans les gens qui
veulent voter donc c'est pas assez
faut se demander pourquoi et en fit le
deuxième problème c'est
dire la gauche parce qu'on dit la gauche
en fait l'ailé gauche on dit de lui il
ya des gosses blé riz si vous demandez à
des gens pourquoi ils sont de gauche
vous demandez à 10 personnes y aura
peut-être dix réponses différentes
si on regarde un petit peu les gauches
il ya quand même jeu j'en viens au fond
mais il ya quand même des points de
fracture majeure il ya la question de la
laïcité une question l'europe et la
question de l'écologie patrick pelloux
il en parlait il ya des gauches qui sont
pour le nucléaire et dès que je sens
contre le nucléaire etc
on peut décliner il ya beaucoup de
besoins fracturé en fait on on fait
comme si tout ça était voué à s'unir
mais c'est pas du tout le cas et on
parle dernier legault mais la réalité
c'est que pour l'instant le candidat le
mieux placé au sein de ces gauches au
pluriel basse et jean luc mélenchon élu
pour le goût il a un programme tout près
il est prêt à y aller mais qui n'est pas
forcément compatible qui n'est pas
forcément compatible mon nez on n'est
pas sûr que les candidats de l'ain soir
c'est la régie pour l'autre mais surtout
par rapport à ce que vous dites par
rapport à la laïcité à la laïcité qui
était d'ailleurs le le le le socle
électoral du parti socialiste et le
parti socialiste par une frange du parti
socialiste s'est éloigné de la laïcité
en prenant un discours sur la laïcité
qui était que la laïcité est une
exclusion c'est faux la laïcité est une
inclusion de tout le monde et il se
trompe et c'est ça la laïcité ça va être
un point d'achoppement et ils vous
verrez ce qui est juste sur les
régionales celle qui a repris le
discours sur la laïcité c'est pécresse
n'a pas été la gauche à droite en grande
partie bien sûr c'est sûr on évoque les
divisions des gauches mais au fond
derrière eto'o était trop jeune pour
vivre le 10 mai 81 ans ou encore un peu
en dessous avez vous entendu pas la
gauche était divisé sur les
improvisations
oui mais même sur le fond et pourtant
l'om il y en aura réussi à les web
allait alors son média et plus possible
aujourd'hui les divisions sont trop
fortes comme en non-vie vous aviez tout
le talent de fonds
c'était autre chose c'est-à-dire que
françois mitterrand était parti il a
fait vraiment un long parcours
si vous aviez une adhésion vous aviez
une discipline de parti
blaye ya plus de discipline bien
honnêtement il ya plus partie d'accord
bon voilà comment vivait encore il ya la
france insoumise et encore ça se
fracturent largement c'est c'est très
compliqué d'avoir une adhésion
collective et surtout ce qui manque là
c'est un programme que si je vous pose
la question quel est le programme du
parti socialiste là bas y en a pas alors
ils vont faire des propositions mais des
propositions par rapport à l'ampleur du
drame de notre pays
l'ampleur du drame c'est là où moi je
suis ce serait plus de dire ouais
l'espèce d'espérance impossible de lui
de l'ubs la poule union d'accord l'union
sacrée de tous tout le monde ensemble et
on remonte le pays et c'est ça qu'on va
regarder c'est ce à quoi vous parlez de
l'offre politique quand on parle de
l'eau des partis etc
mais on peut même partir du bas dir que
en 1981 la gauche c'était quelque chose
de cohérence d une alliance des classes
populaires et d'une partie des couches
moyennes et en ascension notamment les
enseignants
aujourd'hui est ce que là alors on peut
de répondre oui ou non à cette question
mais est-ce que la fraction gauche
droite c'est la division pertinentes
pour la société française en 2017 vous
avez deux candidats au second tour deux
candidats qui rejette le clivage gauche
droite et fait donc on peut se poser la
question on peut répéter la gauche la
gauche la gauche mais peut-être que la
question pour la france n'est pas la
gauche ou la droite aujourd'hui
alors on en revient sur votre couvent
justement est ce que dans ces régionales
il n'y a pas eu ce ce retour du clivage
droite gauche on a vu que les présidents
sortants de droite et bien en sortant de
gauche ont été réélus donc ça veut dire
que c'est quoi ces victoires de gauche
et droite où ces victoires que des
sortants alors ben alors déjà c'est un
flash back de 15 ans en arrière dans la
vie politique française ces régionales
avec une abstention quand même
faramineuses qui est le jeu le phénomène
majeur et alors on peut se demander est
ce que c'est le retour de la gauche ou
la droite ou est ce que c'est la prime
au sortant moi j'ai plutôt tendance à
répondre la prime aux sortants tous les
sortants ont été réélus quasiment sans
exception même sans exception je crois
en dans la folie des métropoles voilà
voilà par la réunion est en réalité
alors nous on a testé les différentes
formules d'union de la gauche et en fait
c'est l'union la plus traditionnelle qui
crée le plus de
dynamique qui est en fait une alliance
ppa 6,9 au premier tour et ensuite vous
avez des électeurs insoumis à écolo qui
ont tendance à voter pour cette histoire
au second tour mais est ce que c'est
cette union de la gauche qui marche le
mieux ou est ce que c'est la prime au
sortant qui marche ne pourra pas le dire
mais le gros score de carole delga le
gros score de carole delga basses
explique tellement en partie par son bon
bilan et en partie par le fait que son
type d'alliance a bien marché c'est un
ps pcf au premier tour mais ça mais au
vu de la france un sauvignon fait la
france assure une mise en effet les
rhénans sont la laïcité après c'est une
régionale c'est pas une présidentielle
oui voilà est-ce que l'on peut appliquer
sa laisse et mélenchon de côté pour la
présidentielle alors que si c'est ça ça
va être impossible c'est un beau signe à
mon avis c'est impossible il aille y en
a qui sait sa vie d'accord il va y est
il a égalé le scénario du bain on doit
aller très bien que si vous avez sept ou
huit candidats de gauche
ils seront jamais au deuxième tour bon
voilà là la seule espérance de pas avoir
marine le pen au deuxième tour c'est si
en effet zemmour se présente il a bouffé
les voit donc peut-être que tout le
monde se dit c'est superbe zemmour se
présente comme ça le pen elle sera pas
au deuxième tour voilà mais le débat qui
a là qu'il devrait passionner la place
politique et il s'en éloigne
c'est l'abstention est ce que la france
grandes démocraties où on a donné
vraiment des tas d'éléments dans
l'histoire pour la démocratie
on laisse cette espèce de deux comme ça
de prétention d'un peuple de dire on va
plus voter n'ont pas d'importance
non moi moi je fais je suis un ardent
partisan du vote obligatoire comme ça se
fait dans d'autres pays parce qu'on peut
pas laisser une démocratie s'écrouler
c'est pas possible c'est c'est
impossible quelle est la légitimité je
sais plus quel journal je crois que
c'est libération qui a fait un rapport
en fait ils ont tous été élus avec 15%
des voix
oui c'est le guen finale le parisien
s'est préparée par les danses de 18%
c'est pas possible donc il faut il faut
d'un coup se poser la question et moi
honnêtement de rendre le vote
obligatoire c'est juste respecter la
démocratie respecter l'histoire de
france et surtout respecter les pays qui
n'ont pas le droit de vote
qu'est ce que c'est que cette espèce de
prétention notre peuple de se dire on va
pas voter alors oui derrière ça en effet
faudra reconnaître le vote blanc ça
c'est sûr ça c'est sûr alors aux joues
roses qu'on revienne quand même sur le
coeur de notre sujet c'était à anne
hidalgo et écouter ce que disait david
cormand qui est eurodéputée europe
ecologie les verts c'était hier sur
public sénat elle vous dit pas souvent
mais anne hidalgo et socialiste je pense
que la social démocratie ne correspond
plus aux n'est plus une réponse aux
enjeux du 21e siècle
et par ailleurs il vous a pas échappé
anne hidalgo et les écologistes à paris
c'est quand même un peu plus que
compliquée tant que c'est compliqué de
se mettre derrière quelqu'un qui
considère que nous serions ambiguë par
exemple avec la république il faut être
cohérent dans la vie
alors on évoque deux sujets
effectivement la bagarre entre les
écolos et les socialistes pour être
devant au moins dans les sondages et en
là on voit dans les élections notamment
parce que david commence hit paris elle
est restée valérie pécresse qui est
arrivé en tête donc pour anne hidalgo
c'est alors qu'il a été classé en plus
le candidat écolo est arrivé devant aux
règles racialiste et ça a été le cas
aussi dans le haut pays de la loire où
matthieu orphelin est arrivé devant le
candidat socialiste alors le problème
c'est que si vous vous écoutez un petit
peu les saucisses et les écolos avant
les régionales ils disaient tous les
deux bon il y aura peut-être une union
rose verte à la présidentielle
reste à savoir quel sera le candidat qui
va l'amener et ça va se décider aux
régionales régionales voilà que les
régionales c'est compliqué parce que les
socialistes ont gardé tout leur région
mais il ya d'autres régions alors c'est
les régions les socialistes n'étaient
pas sortant où les écolos ont fini
devant eux
donc là vous retrouve avec une situation
où le même jour d'ailleurs c'est hier il
y avait anne delvaux qui se présentent
mais il ya aussi violent et elle est
mère de yannick jadot qui sont présentés
et donc vraisemblablement est d'ailleurs
mélenchon l'a dit aujourd'hui dans sa
conférence de presse il y aura il
devrait y avoir un candidat écolo un
candidat socialiste et jean luc
mélenchon pour la gauche lors du 24e
vous comprenez cette accélération n'est
même pas une semaine des régionales on
al impression qu on a tourné la page
vous évoquez personnes tirent les leçons
de l'abstention
et là ils se déclarent tous parlent
quasiment tous candidats où il se met
tant les personnels et or de politique
qu'on a fait ça a été le quinquennat
c'est tout fallait garder le septennat
ils ont plus de temps de souffler il
s'agit d'une hausse par don mello 2006
chirac sait si chirac lui est imposée
quand même oui c'était un peu ça a été
ça a été quand même tu sais c'est quand
même partie ils ont pas le temps de
souffler à ce qui fait qu'il ya cette
espèce d'entre d'eux de notre démocratie
en fait ce que finalement on est sur le
bipartisme à l'américaine avec une tous
les quatre en cinq ans est-ce que c'est
maintenant et là et alors c'est là où ça
reprend parce que c'est lui qui avait
évoqué sa la dernière présidentielle le
débat de mélenchon ne sais pas s'il faut
pas inventer une sixième république
mais là vous avez un tel débat sefas
essayé voilà anne hidalgo il ya il ya
quand même une conception politique il
ya un fond il ya il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas chez les candidats verts
non mais moi je reprends parce que ça
m'a fait marrer mais je reprends ce
qu'avait dit fait quelques routes dans
une interview du figaro qui avait dit le
problème des écologistes et les
écologistes et etc je n'arrive pas à
savoir moi j'ai beaucoup de mal avec les
écologistes un legs parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui sont anti vaccins oui enfin
d'accord donc il y en a beaucoup qui
sont contre le progrès médical parce que
ça rendrait malade et c'est donc ça
s'est un peu c'est à bien leur sujet
j'ai un peu un problème la super enfin
moi mais mais à mon avis le
l'orientation qu'il y assez de se dire
en effet si mélenchon dit il va y avoir
un candidat socialiste vers 1h amour
après vous aurez le npa
vous aurez forcément les à-côtés aussi
pouf pouf vers lui arriver là aussi voit
la lutte ouvrière 5 5 il ya aussi le pcf
auxquels malaria
ils seront pas le deuxième taux c'est
matt evans alors adrien gato vous qui
suivez la vie politique
vous vous imaginez quoi la primaire des
verts déterminera un candidat qui sera
important d'ailleurs parce que oui si
vous avez yannick jadot qui est beaucoup
plus haut à priori dans les sondages que
eric piolle ou sandrine rousseau
peut-être que ça renforcerait
l'hypothèse d'une grenade du revers qui
va vers ce qui va jusqu'au bout alors
que si erik cole un moulin et rousseau
gagne cette primaire et on sait que les
militants verts ont tendance à
privilégier la vie qui est favori et bas
ce sont d'une part des personnages qui
sont moins connus des français mais
c'est aussi des personnages qui sont
beaucoup plus proches de jean luc
mélenchon donc elle aurait quand même
important c'est de regarder de près
cette primaire écologiste avait pensé
qu'il pourrait plus s'allier avec jean
luc mélenchon parce qu'on évoquait jeudi
d'accord possible avec
alors voila mais enfin sur la lazio et
je suis assez d'accord sur la laïcité je
suis assez d'accord parce que quand vous
regardez ce que font les mairies qui ont
basculé et coloriste quand même
largement le communautarisme et en plus
vous avez le le cas de yannick jadot qui
est beaucoup plus proche du ps et puis à
noah legault s'est attaquée directement
au vert en disant qu'il avait des
problèmes avec la république donc ils
ont des problèmes avec 6 yens et daiwa
la candidate du ps alors aussi compliqué
la perspective d'une alliance avec les
écolos alors des internautes qui nous
suivent
le droitiste nous dit mitterrand a tué
la gauche pour 30 ans bon c'est
radicalement la question c'est et
claudius 15 c'est idiot de tirer des
conclusions à partir d'une élection avec
66 % d'abstention ce marais on a tout de
suite dit dès le début qu'il fallait
faire attention à ce qui nous amène à
notre deuxième partie de débat